Now we'd like to discuss
angular acceleration
for circular motion.
So suppose we have our angle
theta, radius r, and r hat
and theta hat.
Recall that we described
the angular velocity
as the derivative of d theta dt,
and we made this perpendicular
to our right-handed coordinate
system, direction k hat.
Now let's differentiate that
to get our concept of angular
acceleration.
So alpha is the second
derivative d theta
dt squared k hat.
And this quantity is what we
call angular acceleration.
Now we'll describe
the component alpha z
as d squared theta dt squared.
So it's the second
derivative of the angle.
And also if we wrote
this as omega z k hat,
we can write that as the
derivative of d omega z dt,
as well.
So this is the component.
And now in circular motion, the
quantities of omega and alpha z
are very much like
the linear quantities
of the x component
of the velocity
and the x component
of the acceleration.
And again, when we've
chosen a reference frame,
let's look at what
various components mean.
Let's begin with the case 1
where omega z is positive.
So when omega z
is positive, that
tells us that the angle
d theta dt is increasing.
And that corresponds to
counterclockwise motion.
Now given that case,
let's look at what happens
when alpha z is positive.
Remember, that's the statement
that d omega dt is positive,
that omega z is increasing.
So if an object is moving with
a positive component of omega z
and the angular acceleration
component is positive,
that corresponds to increasing.
The linear example, if you had
one dimensional motion, i hat,
you had vx positive
and a x positive,
corresponds to an
object increasing
in its speed in the x direction.
That's our first case.
Now let's look at
the second example
when alpha z is less than 0.
So now the derivative of
d omega z dt is negative.
What that corresponds
to-- remember,
omega z is the z component
of the angular speed.
And if that's slowing down,
then, with alpha z less than 0,
the object is slowing down.
So in our linear case, if
we had a x less than 0,
this is the classic
example of breaking.
The object is moving in the
x direction and slowing down.
Now let's look at case 2.
This is always a little bit
complicated for circular motion
where omega z is less than 0.
In that case, the
object is moving
in the clockwise direction
because the angle
theta is decreasing,
corresponding
to clockwise motion.
So in that case, once again,
let's consider the two
examples.
Well, the first example
is a positive component
of angular acceleration.
Now this is the one that can
be a little bit confusing.
The object is moving
clockwise but it
has a positive alpha z,
which will correspond
to slowing the object down.
And if the alpha z
remains positive,
it will actually come to rest
and then reverse its motion
and start to speed up.
So this is the case where
d omega dz is increasing.
And that's our first case.
So something like that
could correspond to,
if we plotted omega z
and we had an object that
starts off with a negative
omega z and increases.
Notice that the slope here,
which is alpha z positive,
corresponds to a positive
angular acceleration component.
And the object slows down
as omega gets closer to 0,
stops, and now has
a positive omega
z, corresponding to motion in
a counterclockwise direction.
For our linear case,
this corresponds
to, again, with i hat, our
object moving to the left,
vx negative, and
if a x is positive,
it breaks in this direction,
which means it's slowing down.
And then eventually if
alpha x, ax, stays positive,
it continues in that direction.
Now our final case, and
I'll put it down here,
b, this is again where omega z
negative and alpha z negative.
It's always helpful to see this
immediately with the graph.
Omega z is negative.
Here, alpha z, which is the
slope, is also negative.
This corresponds
to an object moving
in the clockwise direction.
And actually its
speed is increasing
because alpha z is negative.
So it's going faster and faster
in the clockwise direction,
even though alpha z is negative.
And for our linear
case, again, this
corresponds to an object moving
in the negative x direction.
And a x is negative,
it's moving faster
in the negative x direction.
And so these are
the cases of how
we analyze the various cases
for angular acceleration
and angular velocity.